der Ramsauer würden sie stand heute sie
stünden mit ihrem Häuschen ähm in in
Bayern vor genau diesem Problem müsste
sich eine neue Heizung anschaffen würden
sie im Moment eine Gasheizung
investieren also erstmal sie reden immer
von Häuschen
die Immobilienbesitzer in Deutschland
haben keine Häuschen oder häuslebnis
machen wir auch bei ihnen in der
Printausgabe heißt habe ich vor Jahren
Beleidigung für die Leute die schöne
Zählungen dass die Häuschen oder Häusle
ein blöd das ist der Traum deswegen
ordentliche Häuser sonst würden die auch
die Heizungen
ganz ehrlich wenn ich mein Haus fast
entkernen müsste
die Fußboden rausreißen da
Fußbodenheizungen installieren alles
rumreißen was sich finanziell und
wirtschaftlich nicht regeln würde ich
natürlich in der Situation eine
Gasheizung
einbauentiert worden natürlich nicht
sagen sie nein
das ist doch nicht mehr also das ist mit
tollen Hosen lässt sich gut stinken wer
genügend Geld hat kann sein ganzes Haus
umreißen bestimmt das einzige in der
Mietwohnung also das ist wirklich nichts
volle Hose irgendwie ja Vogel
auch selber kein Geld in die Hand nehmen
auf die Mitte drumherum zu kommen Moment
muss man sich meistens leisten können
sagt Herr Ramsauer in als Replik auf
Herrn doll und sagt natürlich wenn das
die Gegebenheiten sind würde ich
natürlich machen und 70 % der Deutschen
machen genau das im Moment investieren
noch mal eine neue Gasheizung würden Sie
heute in die Kamera sagen falscher Weg
machen sie es nicht mehr ich würde in
jede Kamera sagen dass jedem der heute
eine neue Heizung investiert für Leute
repariere die reparieren wollen und
andere ändert sich jetzt ja durch die
Änderung des Gesetzentwurfes ist nichts
weil ich würde jedem sagen du musst dir
gut überlegen dass dir klar sein muss
bis Mitte des Jahrhunderts müssen wir
klimaneutral sein wir müssen den Weg
finden wie wir das für die Leute machbar
technisch und zweitens finanzierbehalten
und das wird ja zu dem zu der Antwort
auf die Frage von eben was brauchen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ich glaube das
sind mündige Bürger das heißt die
brauchen drei Dinge die brauchen von der
Politik eine klare Vorgabe fürs Ziel wir
alle als Gesellschaft sind in der
Notwendigkeit wir müssen uns Gedanken
machen wie kommen wir dahin dass wir
Mitte des Jahrhunderts unterhitzen
klimaneutral kriegen zweitens die
brauchen Unterstützung zum Beispiel auch
okay völlig ungeklärt werden muss
ich das in deutschen Bundestag
verabschiede muss die Frage der
finanziell Unterstützung für die die
wenig Geld haben geklärt sagen
so viel Zeit und jetzt geht's ums Geld
sie haben den Punkt selber angesprochen
sie schreiben in ihrer Koalition aus dem
Bauministerium aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium Papier sie sitzen
30 Stunden zusammen sie können nicht
mehr aus den Augen gucken und sie haben
kein einziges Mal über das gesprochen
was die Menschen am meisten interessiert
was mit dem eigenen tragen wollten nach
Athen das ist doch genau unser Punkt als
Freie Demokraten gewesen also hat uns
doch ansprechen
also als Abgeordneter im Deutschen
Bundestag dieses Gesetz nicht
verabschieden wenn bis dahin nicht die
Frage des Förderprogramms klar aber sie
verwirren die
menschenrechtskraft tritt da muss
natürlich auch die Frage der Förderung
für diejenigen dann kommt der große
Schock haben nee wir haben doch immer
und Transformation
sein oder gleicher Meinung sein wie sie
aber kann man eine Frage der
Finanzierung kann man die so lange auf
die lange Bank schieben und die Menschen
so sehr sie mir gerade gesagt es gibt
eine große Unklarheit weiterhin sie
wünschen sich mehr Klarheit kann man die
Menschen so lange im Unklaren lassen
über das was es kostet ich bin da ganz
bei Herrn Vogel wir brauchen jetzt
dringend Klarheit auch wieder die
Förderung für die Menschen aussieht wir
müssen da auch die Mittel aufstocken da
ist der Finanzminister gefragt da kann
ihre Partei jetzt auch liefern anstatt
an anderen Stelle zu blockieren das
halte ich für den genau entscheidenden
Punkt und ich hätte mir auch eine andere
Reihenfolge genau da gewünscht um erst
zu erklären wo kommt denn eigentlich die
Förderung her und wie machen wir das
möglich und dann eben auch da die völlig
richtigen Pflichten dann auch zu
verabschieden ich möchte an der Stelle
auch noch mal mit ein paar Vorurteilen
zur Wärmepumpe auf aufräumen es wird
jetzt hier mehrmals gesagt die ist
nichts für den Bestand
selbstverständlich ist die Wasser im
Bestand die funktioniert im Bestand ganz
genauso gut wie sie das im auch im
Neubau tut und da muss man nicht eine
Fußbodenheizung ein bisschen auf das
Haus
Gegebenheit suchen sie sich da suchen
Sie sich dann Energieberater das ist
eine tolle Technologie die auch von
deutschen Ingenieuren und deutschen
Firmen vorangebracht wurde das ist ein
technisches Meisterwerk und haben den
ein bisschen mehr Vertrauen und
Optimismus auch dahin nein aber doch für
die Wärmepumpe haben wir verstanden
bleiben
30 Stunden sitzen sie machen nicht ihr
eigenes Ding hier ganz kurz wir reden
über das Geld jetzt weil das ist
wirklich eine so wichtige Frage für
Millionen Zuschauer und es geht einmal
um die Frage kann man als Koalition
tatsächlich erstmal drüber hinweggehen
kann man Millionen Deutschen erstmal
sagen so wir Zorn erstmal fest 20:45 Uhr
ist aus mit Öl und Gasheizung wir setzen
voll auf die Wärmepumpen wir sagen euch
auch wie teuer so eine Wärmepumpe gibt
aber was Ihr dafür für Förderung bekommt
das klammern wir erstmal aus kann man
jetzt in diesem Fall so machen weil ich
ein Vogel beim Wort nehmen werde und
wenn das Ding nicht verabschiedet wird
ohne also das darf nur verabschiedet
werden wenn wirklich am Ende drin steht
was die Bürger auch was die Bürger an
Fördermitteln kriegen ansonsten darf es
nicht gehen Ich finde es nur aus zwei
Gründen sehr sehr unglücklich muss ich
sagen also laut dem Habeck Entwurf der
dem ersten den wir hatten war überhaupt
nichts dazu drin gestanden und ähm ich
würde sagen in der aktuellen Situation
wo wirklich viele Leute genau rechnen
müssen finde ich das völlig fatal ich
verstehe ja nicht dass wir das nicht
anders thematisiert habt als die varale
in diesem Ausschuss und dass wir das
auch nicht öffentlicher gemacht habt
oder so aber gut vielleicht ist diese
Entwurf ja vom Koalitionspartner
durchgestochen worden und das war eine
der Gründe dass das eine und das hat
vielleicht und das glaube ich nicht dass
er das war ne und ähm also ich finde den
Zeitpunkt sehr unglücklich und dann
haben wir im anderen Punkt eine
Situation wir haben noch nicht mehr
wegwerfen für den Haushalt also ist
grundlegende Finanzierungsfragen nicht
geklärt für die Bundeswehr brauchen wir
zehn Milliarden die Kindergrundsicherung
braucht 12 Milliarden das braucht
wahrscheinlich 9 Milliarden also dass
die Kosten sind 9 Milliarden bis 28 wer
zahlt das am Ende alles das würde mich
interessieren wie kriegen Sie Herr Vogel
ich nehme sie beim Wort wir werden
gucken das Ding wird erst verabschiedet
wenn sie wirklich gesagt haben was die
Leute kriegen gleichzeitig muss dann
aber auch ihr Finanzminister also der
liberale Christian Lindner seine
Schatulle aufmachen muss sagen hier
immer noch mal mehrere Milliarden wie
wollen Sie das machen ja dazu was klares
zu sagen also erstens ich finde das ist
eine Frage der der Vernunft und es muss
natürlich eine Selbstverständlichkeit
sein dass wenn dieses Gesetz was ja noch
nicht mal von Kabinett jetzt
verabschiedet ist sondern was bei
Verbänden liegt zur Anhörung bei
Experten weil der zuständige Minister
ist eben gegeben hat
und bei Bild immer gut informiert ist
und wir sind auf einer Bild Sendung und
ich verstehe die Zuspitzung aber dass
mir wirklich ernst das von der Frage ist
auch eine selbstverständliche Frage der
Vernunft dass wenn das am Ende vom
Parlament verabschiedet wird muss
natürlich die Förderung klar sein erste
Verstärkung vorher kommt überhaupt gar
nicht in Frage das zu verabschieden
Punkt zweitens woher das Geld kommt hat
die Koalition ja im Koalitionsausschuss
beantwortet und das auch absolut richtig
normativen Klima und Transformation
ist ja auch immer Geld zu durch die CO2
Bepreisung und natürlich muss wie viel
flüssiger Programm darauf dass er hängt
natürlich davon ab wie sie CO2 aktuell
rein etwa ja wir haben da absehbar in
dieser Legislaturperiode weiter ein
dreistelligen Milliardenbetrag liegen so
da ist es nicht wenig Geld im Thema und
Transformation und drittens weil sie das
gerade so ein bisschen problematisiert
haben ich finde das absolut richtig dass
wir auf solide Finanzen achten und es
bei den anderen Fragen was können wir
uns leisten in diesem Land bei der
Haushaltsaufstellung der eine Fragen die
hier nicht befasst sind weil der Klima
Transformation steht hier und das ist
der allgemeine Bundeshaushalt dass wir
im allgemeinen Bundeshaushalt hat
erstens die Schuldenbremse wieder
einhalten und dass wir zweitens das tun
dass jede Familie in diesem Land tut
wenn man gerne viele Dinge will muss
priorisieren und kann nicht alles
gleichzeitig sagen das geht eben auch
für den für richtig Punkt sie sind doch
erstens in der Regierung ihre Partei und
zweitens stellen Sie den Finanzminister
all das was sie jetzt hier ankündigen
können sie doch liefern ja aber es hält
uns doch niemand auf der eben ganz genau
es wird doch rechtzeitig da sein bevor
das verabschiedet wird rechtzeitig ist
schon zu spät haben wir auch von Herrn
doll gehört Entschuldigung haben wir
auch von Herzen gehört dass wir uns
immer manche Fragen verhaken aber das
ist wirklich keine wenn das zuständige
Ministerium habe ich ähm jetzt für
diesen veränderten Gesetzentwurf
Feedback der Länder und Verbände haben
zuständig das doch einholen und es ist
doch völlig klar dass erstens ein Gesetz
verabschiedet ist von der Regierung als
Entwurf wenn es durch Kabinett ist und
in der Welt von Herr Berger ist ja nicht
unberechtigt hier steht drin was wie man
die Klimaziele erreichen will hier steht
drin wie man Heizung umrüsten möchte
welche Möglichkeiten die Regierung
schaffen möchte welche technologischen
Möglichkeiten man auch als Wette eingeht
in den nächsten Jahren das steht hier
alles drin aber die Finanzierung die aus
Ihrem Hause kommt aus dem
Finanzministerium aus dem FDP
Finanzminister der steht nicht erstens
Konzept auch alle zuständigen
Ministerien also nicht nur das
Finanzministerium sondern auch das was
fachlich zuständig ist für dieses Thema
ja aber eben nicht Konzept habe ganz
kurz ja auch in seinem allerersten
Entwurf gar kein Finanzier geliefert
Punkt wir können es abschließen weil an
der Stelle müssen wir uns wirklich nicht
weil sie noch nicht sagen können dazu es
gibt entschuldigung ich als
Parlamentarier kommt das sowieso im
nächsten Schritt und ich habe ihn
niemals Parlamentarier was sehr klares
gesagt ja
verabschiedet bis die Förderung nicht
klar wie lange geben sie das auch ihrem
Finanzminister wie lange geben sie dir
Regierung dafür Zeit wann steht die
Finanzierung dafür ich werde jetzt hier
der Regierung keine Fristen setzen aber
bevor das in deutschen Bundestag
verabschiedet ist muss beides zusammen
sein ich gehe fest davon aus dass im
Kabinett schon und dieses Gesetz nicht
im bundestagsabgeordnet ich verstehe die
Höflichkeit gegenüber der eigenen Frage
gegenüber dem Finanzministerium wir
haben auch eine Verantwortung gegenüber
den Millionen Menschen haben eine klare
Zusage gemacht das ist nicht sagen
können wie viel und wann es kommen
auch klar genannt und dann habe ich auch
nicht leicht hin ich habe den Zuschauern
und Zuschauern eben gesagt sie können
sich bei mir und bei den Freien
Demokraten drauf verlassen dieses Gesetz
kommt nicht durch den Deutschen
Bundestag wird nicht vom Parlament
verabschiedet wenn ich gleichzeitig die
Finanzierungsfrage klar ist Punkt sie
wollen aber eben nicht sagen wie lange
sie drauf hatten müssen und sie haben
Herrn Hamburg gehabt habe ich doch jetzt
eine ganze Menge entstammbuch
geschrieben und noch verlangt was hier
drin noch diskutiert werden muss
schreiben Sie das doch ihrem eigenen
Finanzminister genauso ins Stammbuch und
sagen sie doch jetzt mal was eigentlich
jetzt an Finanzierungen für dieses
Projekt für dieses wichtige Projekt das
Klimaschutz ist eigentlich noch
notwendig ist aus ihrer
Regierungserfahrung ist das normal dass
man in solchen Stunden Nachtsitzung noch
und Löcher am Ende die wirklich
knackigen Fragen dann ausklammert weil
man weiß mit dem Haarwerk da kommen wir
heute nicht zusammen und dann müssen
halt Millionen Deutsche einfach mal
warten ja dann sagen mit denen halt
nicht was das geben muss wirklich an
vielen Stellen jetzt schmunzeln weil ich
viele viele Jahre das gleiche mitgemacht
habe
im Bundestag und daran dass der Kabinett
Verantwortung und
ich gesteht im Kollegen Vogel wirklich
zu dass er das alles ernst meint aber da
kann ich nur sagen gute Reise und ich
glaube auch dass sie sich das fest
vorgenommen haben das alles
durchzusetzen und so aber das sind doch
die nächsten krache innerhalb der Ampel
schon vorprogrammiert also wenn jemand
Koalitionsausschuss sehr Wert bis zu
mehr brechen mitgemacht aber wenn wir
jemals damals 30 Stunden gebrauchte
hätten mit dem dünnen Ergebnis mit einer
Unterbrechung ohne Zwischenergebnis da
wäre die Medien Republik Kopf gestanden
also wer 30 Stunden für sowas braucht
hat keine Gemeinsamkeiten mehr muss ich
mal ganz ehrlich gesagt ja genau
morgen die FDP ist natürlich in einer
schwierigen Situation weil das ist
manchmal befeuer und Wasser sie mit
ihrer liberalen Grundeinstellung die ich
selber aus vollem Herzen mittrage aber
auf der anderen Seite dieses
missionarische Moralisierung
tut
mir leid vielleicht reagieren
nickte fleißiger als der Ramsauer die
Koalition mal eben auseinander haben ja
genau weil ich meine das was wir jetzt
mir also 30 Stunden war es wirklich sehr
lange das muss ich wirklich sagen aber
wer in uns ist noch an die groko
erinnern uns unseren endlose
koalitionsausschüsse mit dem über
nächtigen CSU Politik die Augen gelegt
habe
zehn Stunden das war in der Nacht vom
zweiten Auftritten juli 2006 da waren
wir um 25 fertig mit einem fertigen
neuen Konzept in verschieden allerdings
auch sagen dass in dieser Gruppe liegen
geblieben geblieben ist aber jetzt muss
man einen Vogel mal beim Wort nehmen es
wird mich mal was interessieren also ich
finde es wirklich
unglücklich dass man jetzt diesen
Vorstoß jetzt macht und die Leute eben
nicht die von Herrn zärger zu Recht
eingeforderte Planbarkeit hat deswegen
frage ich jetzt wann können denn wann
ist dieses Gesetz so weit wann wissen
denn die Leute mit welcher Förderung Sie
rechnen können ist das eine Sache von
Wochen von Monaten oder von Jahren ganz
genau ja das glaube ich das glaube ich
nicht von ja und der aber das ist
deswegen muss ja irgendwie im Laufe des
Jahres Weg so also wann kommt das Ding
ist was könnten Sie sich denn als
Förderung vorstellen was ist möglich was
ist drin und dann müssen wir das
hochrechnen und dann muss
ich auf den Vorschlag der Regierung das
vernünftig dass die jetzt erstmal einen
in Ruhe besprechen zum Zeitplan kann ich
ganz klar sagen die Regierung hat
angekündigt dass sie den Ehrgeiz hat
dieses Parlament dieses diesen
Gesetzentwurf immer April durchs
Kabinett zu bringen und dann geht er
danach an den Deutschen Bundestag und
dann fangen wir
im Frühjahr an zu diskutieren und wir
werden so lange diskutieren wie ein
parlamentarisches Verfahren nötig ist
dann muss ich auch noch das ist mit
Bundesrat schon Nein unwahrscheinlich
müsste die cdu/csu wenn schon mitmachen
weil wir hier Fristen haben und
oppositionsrecht sind aber dieses dieses
Jahr rechtzeit um den Sommer entweder
vor oder nach der Sommerpause glaube ich
kriegt man auf einen guten Weg sein aber
vielleicht darf ich auf einen Ramsauer
noch ganz kurz wichtig ist will ich auch
so nicht stehen lassen also wir ähm bei
allem wechselseitigen Respekt und
wechselseitiger Wertschätzung und ich
will gar nicht aufzählen was sie uns
alles hinterlassen
also bei allen großen Herausforderungen
war ja konzeptionell und bei der
Gestaltung nichts da und in den 30
Stunden ich wünsche mir auch dass es
schneller geht und ich wünsche mir auch
dass wir stärker Vorankommen aber in
dieser letzten Woche was haben wir was
haben wir hier beschlossen mehr Tempo
bei der Schiene mehr Tempo bei der
Straße inklusive Autobahn mehr Tempo bei
den erneuerbaren Energien mehr Tempo bei
langsam
von ihnen verschleppt das Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz mit Punktesystem
aller kanadischen Vorbild ob in einer
Woche also im Vergleich das kann sich
mit sie haben genau wenn sie es umsetzen
kriegen sie den nötigen Respekt dafür
wenn sie tatsächlich mehr Tempo überall
schaffen auf Papier ist auch zu
schreiben
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie